new hospitalization numbers show an
alarming jump in the number of children
affected by covet 19 a study in the
journal jama pediatrics finds more than
5 300 children
and teenagers in 22 states were
hospitalized with the disease
between may and november denise valdez
joining us now with
more in today's health watch
well christian we are talking about
multi-system inflammatory syndrome and
we have had a handful of cases here in
nevada and clark county
the symptoms can present really just
like any other virus but it can lead to
some serious complications
which in that case is going to be that
inflammation we've been talking about
now you would never guess that
eight-year-old van fuqua is bouncing
back from a disease that left him
struggling in a hospital bed now his
mother kate got the virus in november so
the entire family quarantined as a
precaution
a month later van was hit with fatigue
first
then a fever of 104 degrees a rash on
his body he had strawberry tongue
and trouble walking now this is
interesting he tested negative for strep
the flu and two covet tests came back
negative
leaving doctors just scrambling to
figure out what was wrong
he had some really scary numbers on his
labs like his heart was
in heart failure his kidneys looked bad
his liver looked bad
so they were really scrambling trying to
figure out you know
which one of these systems is the
culprit and none of them were
it was all an inflammation reaction to
the virus
so the culprit was the cobit-19 virus
and the diagnosis was misc
short for multi-system inflammatory
syndrome now it is relatively rare
but the complication often presents
itself in
in children more states across the
country are now reporting
increases in pediatric cobit
hospitalizations take a look at the map
in utah a 5 000 increase
arizona 4 000 wisconsin south dakota
ohio and minnesota
are all reporting a more than 1 1 000
increase in these cases in kids now
since
may there have been around 1700 cases of
multi-system inflammatory syndrome
and 26 deaths and remember it can pop
up long after cobit is gone children
with misc
may have fever various symptoms things
from including like abdominal pain
vomiting diarrhea neck pain rash and
bloodshot eyes or they're just feeling
really extra tired so something to be
aware of
as we start to slowly now phase out from
the cobit 19.
back to you guys